at citi field in new york the new york
mets play the miami marlins in the first
game of a doubleheader now it's been a
long span of time since the mets last
played a baseball game and so there'll
be two for the price of one today rick
porcello 344 career starts this is only
his second against the mariners one win
in the national league 149 in the
america jonathan vr leads off the 3-2
from porcello and he gets vr on the high
fastball and that's how this day of
baseball begins matt joyce has a
seven-game hitting streak going
and he strikes out
matt joyce with the change-up and
porcello's got back-to-back strikeouts
to start the day good arm action good
pitch it's dan castano on the mound for
the marlins today and castano is coming
off a a short start that was by design
jd davis sitting second in the order
jd finds the hole on the right side and
sneaks one into the outfield for the
first hit of the day
jd has really worked up the middle in
that opposite gap so far in this
well i can't call it young season so one
out and one on now michael conforto
taking the other way and the mets again
take advantage of the shift first jd and
now conforto both
putting light of the shift and the mets
have two men on well good hitting by
michael and that's what he's been doing
hitting left-handers really well this
year starting with the cleanup inner
brian anderson
passive aggressive swing at velocity
well that was aggressive wasn't it 88 i
like it pulled through his hands nice
job one hop off the wall and it's going
to be a lead off double for brian
anderson saw a few pitches in that
at-bat and then comes through with a
double he worked the count against
porcella got a fastball up 88 miles an
hour great job pulling the hands in
alright see if brenson can do something
two on and two out
that is a sharply hit ball that gets
through it's a base hit
rounding third and scoring there is no
play at third brenson gets to second
anderson crosses home plate and the
marlins have a one-nothing lead all
right sweet lou getting it done not
waiting around first fastball he gets
inner third we talked about the righties
pulls his hands through and hits a
rocket through the left side nobody has
been better in baseball with two outs
here's miguel rojas 3-2 and rojas base
hit right field alfaro scores brenson
coming around and he's in there marlins
get a couple more miggy to second it's
three nothing oh how many times have we
seen mickey row go the other way paul he
continues to do it quality advanced
professional at that matt joyce leading
off in the third 2-2 coming to joyce
and he gets them looking joyce strikes
out for the second time
third strikeout for porcello and that's
the first out of the third 1-2 to
dickerson and he picks off the inside
corner again so porcello against the two
left-hand hitters joyce and dickerson
set him up and put him down
diaz settling in another 3-2 pitch that
one is hit through the right side and a
base hit anderson rounding third here
comes the throw from right it's cut off
and lewin diaz has himself an rbi the
first of his major league career and
it's four to nothing consultation with
the grounds crew the umpires have
decided to have them cover the field as
you might be able to hear is really
kicking up it looks like we're about to
have a doozy of a thunderstorm so
it looks like they uh they guessed right
although the tarp is there oh the tarps
that's no good so now we get back
underway as we start at the bottom of
the third brandon nimmo leads off
against daniel castano 1-0 pitch from
castano is stroked out to right field
coming in sanchez makes the play
what a first week defensively for
sanchez he's already made a couple of
pretty nice plays miguel rojas singled
to drive in two runs in the second
inning and he drives this one out to
left field dom smith going back down to
the warning track right at the wall and
he made the catch right at the orange
line terrific play by dom smith to take
an extra base hit away from miguel rojas
so the mets for the fourth consecutive
inning get a runner into scoring
position they're all for four so far
and he hits one right to the shortstop
rojas and that'll do it so the mets
continue to leave base runners that's
five of them in the first four innings
two strikes now three and two
and he got him
strikes him out his first of the night
and it comes in the fifth inning
balling a strike to rosario
and a comebacker
boxberger
makes the play to end the inning that's
a bit shut out for the first six innings
of a seven inning game brandon nimmo
leads off in the home seven
and nimo slugs one toward the gap in
left center brinson closing ground but
he can't get him and nimmo will go to
second
he'll take a turn there and hold up with
a lead-off double so the mets have
something started in the final inning
and now the mets are down to their final
out in game one
[Applause]
that is lined to rojas it's a marlins
win
so they take the first game of this four
game series